Tradutor: roberto tobo
Revisor: Custodio Marcelino
♪ Se essa rua
Se essa rua fosse minha
Eu mandava, eu mandava ladrilhar
Com pedrinhas, com pedrinhas de brilhantes
Para o meu, para o meu amor passar
Nessa rua, nessa rua tem um bosque
Que se chama, que se chama solidão
Dentro dele, dentro dele mora um anjo
Que roubou, que roubou meu coração
Se eu roubei, se eu roubei seu coração
É porque tu roubaste o meu também
É porque, é porque te quero bem
Quem te ensinou a nadar?
Foi, foi, marinheiro,
foi os peixinhos do mar
Quem te ensinou a nadar?
Foi, foi, marinheiro,
foi os peixinhos do mar
Como pode um peixe vivo
viver fora da água fria?
Como poderei viver, como poderei viver
Sem a tua, sem a tua, sem a tua companhia
Eu não sou daqui, eu só tenho amor,
Eu sou da Bahia de São Salvador
Marinheiro só
Eu não sou daqui, marinheiro só
Eu só tenho amor, marinheiro só
Eu sou da Bahia, marinheiro só
De São Salvador, marinheiro só
Marinheiro, marinheiro, marinheiro só
Quem te ensinou a navegar? Marinheiro só
Ou foi o tombo do navio, marinheiro só
Ou foi o balanço do mar, marinheiro só
Lá vem, lá vem, marinheiro só
Ele vem faceiro, marinheiro só
Todo de branco, marinheiro só
Com seu bonezinho, marinheiro só
Lá vem, lá vem, marinheiro só
Ele vem faceiro, marinheiro só
Todo de branco, marinheiro só
Com seu bonezinho, marinheiro só
Quem te ensinou a nadar?
Foi, foi, marinheiro,
foi os peixinhos do mar
Quem te ensinou a nadar?
Foi, foi, marinheiro,
foi os peixinhos do mar
foi os peixinhos do mar ♪
(Aplausos)